this is Chef kiss beautiful tweet from
Charlie Kirk
Obamas complained about being black
oppressed from a luxury yacht in the
Greek Islands after affirmative action
overturned by Supreme Court look at that
fancy yacht I have never been on a yacht
of that nature Connor have you ever
Phoenix ever been on a brock never been
on a oh
Brock has been on the open
that's funny Brockman on the Obamas
yacht we'll find out more about that but
that's it right there right this guy who
now is worth hundreds of millions of
dollars who was a community organizer
somehow becomes president of the United
States hope and change it obviously all
failed which is why we get his VP as the
president now and all the rest of that
30-acre estate on the water Martha's
Vineyard climate change don't worry
about that and he's tweeting about
oppression for black people on the yacht
by the way I'm being informed right now
this is very exciting Barack Obama was
on that yacht in the Greek Islands with
Tom Hanks
[Music]
foreign